[Musique]
bonsoir à tous bienvenue dans le 7-8
journal sur tv 78 nous sommes le jeudi 8
novembre tout de suite les titres de
cette édition
l'édifice doit voir le jour l'an
prochain à maurepas le chantier du
multiplexe a débuté la première pierre
de ce projet à 13 millions d'euros a été
posée ce matin et huit salles 1700
fauteuil pour ce nouveau cinéma
implantée dans la zone paris ouest près
du village des loisirs
ce dimanche nous commémorons les 100 ans
de la signature de l'armistice le 11
novembre 1918 il mettait fin à la
première guerre mondiale
à cette occasion montigny le bretonneux
va accueillir la flamme de l'arc de
triomphe nous en parlons avec
jean-claude bouvier président de la
section locale de l'union nationale des
combattants
et puis ce ver hyérois est le lauréat du
prix des nouvelles écritures de france
télévisions ibou ndiaye est distingué
pour son court métrage les enfants du
bois de l'étang présenter au concours
film ton quartier il voulait dire y être
et notre invité avec lydia salah et
mohamed qui apparaissent dans le film
dans l'actualité du jour d'abord la
troisième édition du à sky business day
au vélodrome national de saint quentin
en yvelines
tout au long de la journée des
dirigeants de grandes entreprises de pme
de tpe et de start up se sont rencontrés
et des rendez-vous de 25 minutes pour
découvrir tenter de convaincre pour
conclure des affaires
plus de mille participants représentant
près de 700 entreprises
ecoutez jean michel fourgous président
de saint quentin en yvelines au micro de
nicolas landry et de patrick jacques de
dixmude
on est ici pour inventer pour pour pour
accélérer la croissance de nos
entreprises
et ça passe bien sûr par la création
d'événements de ce type
comprenez là pour que les petits surtout
aux entreprises qui ont du mal les
pouvoirs à rentrer en relation avec une
grande entreprise avoir le bon décideurs
pour vendre leurs produits mais ici on
est un démultiplicateur de rencontres
entre les petites entreprises et les
grosses entreprises pour qu'ils
travaillent plus ensemble
on prend tout de suite la direction de
maurepas à la pose de la première pierre
du futur multiplexe s'est déroulée
aujourd'hui en face du village des
loisirs une structure qui sera
construite en bois avec huit salles
dernière génération les détails avec ce
sujet de michael et demi d'euros dans 12
mois ce terrain vague deviendra l'un des
plus grands multiplexes des yvelines la
pose de la première pierre du futur
cinéma de maurepas était organisée ce
jeudi 8 novembre en face du village des
loisirs avec mon équipe on a évidemment
très très heureux c'est l'aboutissement
de longues années de travail pour voir
enfin arriver un cinéma à maurepas
multiplex qui va davantage en attractif
évidemment le village et loisirs la zone
d'activités on va parler de maurepas
évidemment en termes maintenant culturel
assez assez fort puisque le cinéma c'est
aussi une dimension culturelle
mais c'est aussi une grande locomotive
pour la zone le cinéma pour accueillir
près de 1700 personnes réparties dans 8
salles pour garantir une immersion
totale au spectateur l'exploitant a
décidé d'investir près de 13 millions
d'euros
il y aura des écrans qui vont prendre la
couleur de l'ambiance de l'image on
prolonge l image dans la salle et après
il y aura une salle my3d les fauteuils
bouge il ya des éclairs il ya de la
pluie pas de l'appui le brumisateur de
la fumée quand il y aura du brouillard
enfin voilà tout un tas de choses qui
feront qu'on sera vraiment immergé dans
le film des salles dernier cri qui
pourrait attirer près de cinq cent mille
visiteurs par an selon les exploitants
ce dimanche nous commémorons la date du
11 novembre 1918
jour de la signature de l'armistice
mettant fin à la première guerre
mondiale un événement particulier cette
année puisqu'il mettra fin aux
commémorations du centenaire de la
grande guerre entamée depuis 2014
toutes les communes de saint quentin en
yvelines organise leur cérémonie ça
débute à 9h30 à montigny le bretonneux
rue de la mare au carat rendez vous fixé
à 10 heures 30 au monument aux morts
pour trappe et les clayes-sous-bois sur
le parvis de l'hôtel de ville à magny
les hameaux et au cimetière de maurepas
à la verrière un cortège se réunira dès
10h15
10h15 également pour elle en cours ou le
départ est prévu à la ferme du mousseau
plusieurs cérémonies commenceront à 11
heures c'est le cas à coignières et
plaisir qui convie la population devant
leur monument aux morts respectifs et
aussi pour guyancourt et voisins le
bretonneux avec un rassemblement devant
les mairies enfin à villepreux la
journée sera lancée à partir de 9 heures
à la maison des pulpes humain sachez que
chaque chaque ville pardon à son
programme particulier autour du 11
novembre notamment des cloches qui
sonneront dans les communes à 11 heures
et je vous invite pour ce faire à
consulter les différents sites internet
pour connaître l'ensemble des programmes
ces commémorations reprendront en tout
cas une tournure particulière à montigny
le bretonneux la commune est l'une des
35 en france à accueillir cette année à
la flamme du souvenir de l'arc de
triomphe celle de la tombe du soldat
inconnu pour en parler un invité m'a
rejoint un plateau jean-claude bouvier
bonsoir bonsoir à vous êtes le président
de la section locale de l'union
nationale des combattants
alors cette flamme va parcourir la ville
samedi soir on va en parler recevoir
cette flamme à montigny le bretonneux
qu'est ce que ça vous fait puisque c'est
une fierté
abbas est une fierté bien évidemment
parce que c'est quand même quelque chose
de sacré le fait d'aller chercher
l'argent à l'arc de triomphe avec des
enfants des élus un porte drapeau
elle a ramené dans montigny c'est quand
même quelque chose d'exceptionnel com et
vous vous l'évoquez vous étiez allé avec
le conseil municipal des jeunes a à
cette flamme du sur la tombe du soldat
inconnu que ça c'était cette année
c'était cette année
alors vous êtes le président l'a dit vu
luân ces sections ontinyent le
bretonneux l'ufc qui fait tout comme
alors qui commémore également cette
année ses 100 ans puisque lui et ça a
été créé deux semaines seulement après
la fin de la première guerre mondiale
c'est georges clemenceau qui avait créé
le nc
à l'époque quelles sont les missions et
les actions de l'ue est nécessaire le nc
a été créées par georges clémenceau et
leur agrément père brottier d'accord qui
est aumônier militaire et qui circulait
dans les tranchées qui allait voir les
blessés et les malades
donc c'est nos deux pères fondateurs de
ces importants précisé il ya un deuxième
père fondateur et du coup les les
actions l'émission de l'ump la mission
c'est bien sûr la passation de la
mémoire
et puis lui on sait où on va nous sommes
on parle d' anciens combattants mais en
plus nous sommes des combattants de la
paix 1une dirigeants surtout vers les
jeunes nous avons des actions pour les
cérémonies commémoratives pour la vente
des bleuets pour des expositions nous
faisons actuellement dans de belles
expositions
nous avons eu des écoles déjà qui sont
venus nous voir où il va en parler dans
un instant
et du coup ce devoir de mémoire
entretenu vous l'entretenez auprès des
jeunes notamment en quoi c'est important
finances se souvenir aussi de ces
personnes sont mortes il ya cent ans 18
millions de personnes au total si on
compte les pertes civiles et militaires
de cette première guerre mondiale le oui
un petit peu plus mais bon les plus de
18 millions jouer bas c'est important
parce qu'il faut pas oublier tout ce que
des grands anciens en fait pour que nous
soyons aujourd'hui un petit peu empêche
dirais donc qu'ils ont eue ils ont fait
des grands sacrifices et puis si vous
voulez nous on veut trans et ça aux
jeunes mais les jeunes sont très
intéressés à ces demandeurs maintenant à
un moment donné il n'était pas trop pas
trop demandeur mais maintenant les
lycées les écoles
il en sort au programme d'accord ils
sont très intéressés et quand ils
viennent nous voir et il nous pose
beaucoup de questions ils sont bien sûr
intéressés par nos expositions et on
imagine chaque année ce grand temps fort
de ces commémorations du 11 novembre
commence assez préparés pour l'une c'est
vous parliez tout à l'heure d'exposition
notamment une exposition sur les armes
et objets qui ont été utilisés pendant
les conflits qui a à voir dans vos
locaux qui savent qui est à voir dans le
nouveau coach heureux d'avoir au choix
parlez nous un peu de cette exposition à
tahiti d'exposition nous avons fait
appel à des collectionneurs privés bien
sûr et
amateurs donc on a il ya de tout il ya
des armes qui ne sont plus utilisables
bien évidemment il ya des cas ce qu'il
ya des objets aggravée par les poilus
dans les tranchées il ya un petit peu de
sous il ya des lettres de poilus des
lettres très poignante ça faut
absolument lire ça c'est vraiment quand
on lit ça mais moi qui suis qui baigne
un peu dedans il ya des choses j'ai
découvert des choses quand on lit ça on
ressort par aden donc des documents
exceptionnels a déjà complètement à la
deezer ces quatre dernières années
marqué les commémorations des 100 ans de
la première guerre mondiale qui vont
finalement se terminer ce 11 novembre
1918 qu'on arrivera à la fin du
centenaire de la de la grande guerre ici
avec certaines émotions aussi de
terminer ce cycle de quatre ans bien
évidemment bien évidemment parce que
nous avons commencé déjà en 2014 puis il
ya eu 15 16 17 il ya eu aussi pas mal de
petites cérémonies pour justement
continuer préparer 2018
bien sûr il ya une émotion déterminer sa
surtout par un événement pareil que le
centenaire alors revenons justement à
l'événement de samedi et dimanche c'est
l'accueil de la flamme du souvenir à
montigny le bretonneux
elle va pouvoir parcourir la ville
samedi soir entre 18h30 et 21h tout à
fait circuler dans les quartiers à bord
d'un triporteur
donc on va la ramener dans une lampe
tempête bien évidemment parce que avec
le vent et les intempéries faut que ça
soit protégé pour qu'on puisse la
ramener le lendemain matin au monument
aux morts par des torches et allumer la
vasque qui sera devant le money money
donc voilà on a vu le parcours de cette
fin elle s'affiche à l'écran vous l'avez
dit où il ya cette flamme on ira un
cortège il y aurait encore une haie
d'honneur qui lui sera consacré le j'en
ai un grand cortège doit partir de
l'hôtel de ville jusqu'au monument aux
morts
nous rejoindrons avec beaucoup de jeunes
ya des jeunes qui vont porter la flamme
et donc on rejoindra le monument aux
morts je pense qu'on sera arrivé pour
22h45
oula débutera la cérémonie avec le
ravivage symbolique de la flamme qui on
viendra sur cette présence de la flamme
du souvenir à montigny dans notre
édition du lundi merci jean claude
bouvier d'avoir été avec nous merci à
eux
je rappelle que vous êtes le président
de la section de montigny le bretonneux
de l'union des anciens combattants tout
le programme part dans l'union nationale
des combattants pardon et tout le
programme de ces commémorations à
montigny sont à retrouver sur le site
internet de la ville qui s'affiche un
lieu mythique du passé pour présenter
les véhicules de demain l'estaca basée à
montigny le bretonneux donné rendez vous
hier à l'autodrome de linas montlhéry en
essonne ces étudiants ont présenté sur
cet ancien circuit farr leurs concepts
de véhicules innovants
reportage de patrick jacques de dixmude
et de manon barral d'eau
c'est une première pour les étudiants de
l'estaca l'école d'ingénieurs
spécialisée dans les nouvelles mobilités
proposé de découvrir et de tester les
véhicules innovants conçus par les
élèves
ils se sont déplacés de montigny le
bretonneux à l'autodrome de linas
montlhéry en essonne c'est pour mettre à
l'honneur la vie associative de notre
école ses étudiants ses partenaires ses
sponsors ses anciens élèves
donc les mettre à l'honneur voir les
véhicules en statique et en dynamique
qui vient évidemment on est accueilli
par notre partenaire industriel qui est
le groupe ithaque qui bénéficie
d'équipements prestigieux sur un circuit
centenaire parmi les véhicules innovants
conçus par les étudiants calypso son
poids à vide est de 37 kg ce véhicule
thermique de l'association pv 3e est
arrivé troisième aux derniers shell eco
marathon de londres
dans la catégorie moteur à combustion
interne calypso a parcouru plus de 1500
kilomètres avec un seul litre d'essence
on est un moteur qui ne consomme pas
c'est vrai c'est vraiment le nerf de la
guerre au niveau du shell eco marathon
c'est le moteur voilà on a également
l'aérodynamique avoir un véhicule qui
pénètrent bien dans l'air ici on voit
qu'il a été particulièrement soignée et
ensuite avoir finalement une dernier
point une bonne rigidité du châssis en
lui-même qui permettent donc voilà de
perdre on perd le minimum d'énergie en
fait dans le véhicule tout entier lors
de son passage
ce véhicule a réussi à repousser les
limites de l'efficacité énergétique des
technologies utilisées par les étudiants
que l'on pourrait retrouver dans
l'automobile de demain
suite et fin à présent de notre dossier
sur les déserts médicaux nous allons ce
soir à la verrière où la situation
médicale est très préoccupante depuis
février les 6000 habitants de la commune
se retrouvent sans médecin généraliste
les explications de marie lehn yapi
chinois et de nicolas d'android à la
verrière un cabinet médical vide
l'un des médecins étant obligé de partir
pour raisons de santé
l'autre ne pouvait plus assurer les
frais du cabinet seule la commune se
retrouve sans aucun médecin depuis huit
mois
j'ai encore un médecin mais qui à 67 ans
home est nul quand il va partir je sais
pas ce que je ferais chier
j'irai à l'hôpital qu'est-ce qu'on veut
qu'on fasse donc on peut que ça peut pas
durer comme ça il faut construire une
maison de santé maisons de santé qui
n'est resté qu'au stade de projet suite
à un problème de santé suit aussi une
modification de la politique de la ville
qui ne souhaitait plus mettre un budget
dans la construction d'un cabinet et qui
voulait transférer le
le support financier la même semaine
donc faire venir des médecins au sein
des mauvaises donc dû mais un désaccord
avec les médecins libéraux et depuis ce
projet est tombé à l'eau
on était sûr de 50 % des financements la
ville devant forcément de toute façon m
25 % et 25 % restants qui n'était pas
encore complètement acquis celle
organismes de mutuelle générale de
l'éducation nationale mgen qui a
finalement proposé d'ouvrir ses locaux
même jeu elle nous avait bien certifié
que grosso modo on pouvait occuper les
locaux comme un centre de santé que les
médecins étaient tout à fait libres
comme si c'était ailleurs une solution
intéressante financièrement pour les
collectivités locales mais qui inquiète
les médecins libéraux quant à leur
indépendance
le projet s'étend aujourd'hui acteurs de
la santé de la commune et municipalités
partagent la même inquiétude pour la
santé des 6000 habitants de la verrière
la mer a lancé des démarches auprès de
l' agence régionale de santé avec la
maire du mesnil saint denis une commune
voisine dont les médecins arrivent à un
âge avancé dernier recours en date de la
verrière une pétition adressée à la rs
qu'elle fait signer à ses habitants je
pense que la mairie de la verrière
avaient anticipé ce départ en retraite
voilà malheureusement pour l'instant ça
ne porte pas encore ses fruits mais je
pense que ça va se mettre en place de
manière progressive mais encore une fois
je vous rappelle le principe de libre
installation des médecins des médecins
qui peine à se laisser séduire par
l'offre actuelle malgré les aides
proposées la verrière est classé en zone
d'intervention prioritaire par la rs il
faut un projet il faut souvent que les
anciens amène ce projet et parce que ses
anciens auront créé un projet de
notamment de cabinets de groupe et c'est
qu'ils attireront les plus jeunes à
venir
une situation d'autant plus préoccupante
que la verrière portent des projets
d'aménagement et de développement de la
ville comme dans le quartier gare bécane
avec la construction de 1000 logements
mais rassurez vous pas que des mauvaises
nouvelles à la verrière des très bonnes
aussi avec vous ives ndiaye bonsoir être
le réalisateur des enfants du bois de
l'étang c'est un court métrage qui a été
distinguée au concours film ton quartier
de france télévisions le court métrage
est récompensé parmi 200 films du prix
spécial des nouvelles écritures de
france télévisions il vous sera remis le
15 novembre à paris et vous êtes venus
lydia et cela à ma droite bonsoir et moi
même à gauche qu'on soit bon sens et
vous avez vous participé à ce court
métrage on vous voit dans ce court
métrage on va regarder d'ailleurs tout
de suite un extrait mois un militant
croissance un bond de détails
613 les boîtes aux lettres toi mille
habitants ici c'est le voir des lettons
p
[Musique]
un court métrage que vous pouvez
retrouver en intégralité sur la page
youtube hibou production alors trois
narrateurs pour la forme trois musiciens
sur le fond et un dj qui balance la
sauce les enfants du bois de l'étang
c'est un film contre-pied sur ce
quartier du bois de l'étang
il bosse c'est un quartier qui souffre à
tort d'une mauvaise image
ce quartier du bois de l'étang
médiatiquement parlant oui après les
habitants et ceux qui connaissent le
quartier je pense qu ils connaissent le
bois de l'étang ils savent qu'il ya une
énergie
quand on a vu dans les extraits du du
court métrage précédent et les enfants
offrir un super beau boulot pendant les
vacances surtout donc on a fait ça
pendant les vacances d'été
d'accord donc surtout mois d'août donc
et une préparation au niveau des
comédiens et aussi de l'équipe technique
parce que dans l'équipe technique il y
avait aussi des enfants donc par exemple
le régisseur et l'ingénieur du son était
les enfants qu'on avait formé avec mon
équipe et pourquoi ça vous tenait à
coeur de participer à ce concours film
ton quartier bas tout d'abord c'est un
quartier où j'ai habité pendant à peu
près 17 ans donc j'ai passé une partie
de ma jeunesse là bas et les enfants au
bois de l'étang à la verrière c'est une
particularité dans ce quartier c'est
qu'il ya énormément d'enfants qui a
énormément d'enfants et je trouve que
c'est une partie pour moi de la
population et devait de s'exprimer à
travers un court métrage est un court
métrage très bien réussi parce qu'ils
ont obtenu le prix des nouvelles
écritures par france télévisions c'est
un court métrage vous l'avez dit qui est
réalisé par vous et les enfants ça vous
vous tenez à le préciser
c'est une fierté pour vous qu'il soit
visible un niveau national il sera
projeté sur france 3 le 6 décembre
c'est ça il sera projeté sur france 3 le
6 décembre et il faut savoir que le bois
de l'étang nationalement parlant il
n'est pas très connu donc lui donner une
exposition comme celle là je pense que
ça ça va faire du bien surtout avec ce
qui s'est passé dernièrement dans les
médias avec l'épisode du jdd
dubois de l'epan donc là ça va faire du
bien aux bois de l'étang et les enfants
aujourd'hui ils ont aussi une une
une vidéo à présenter à leurs proches à
leur famille etc
et je pense que c'est une satisfaction
pour eux mais bon je pense qu'ils vont
ils peuvent vous l'expliqué le fonds a
fait un tour de table avec les enfants
qu'est ce que ça vous a fait de
participer à ce film allez ça là on va
commencer avec toi c'est intéressant
c'était bien j'ai bien aimé ça m'a plu
mais il ya aussi l'expérience c'était
intéressant pour toi c'était très bien
c'était vraiment intéressant
il y avait plein de trucs intéressante
c'était vraiment bien
qu'est-ce qui avait d'intéressant par
exemple qu'est ce que tu as pu découvrir
j'ai pu découvrir le drapeau quand elle
lancé et quand on devait faire un point
et en deux moitiés temps et toi moi
maître qu'est ce qui t'a plu dans ce
projet dans le fait d'y participer
c'est bien de découvrir de nouvelles
choses sur sur le cinéma ce qu'est vidéo
et mon cerveau bien plus de jeu du
saxophone au sénégal et en france
mais si on te voit dans ce court métrage
jouer du saxophone ton quartier le bois
de l'étang il représente quoi pour toi
la ville
si où j'habite
et vous les filles le bois de l'étang ça
vous inspire quoi c'est vous le dire en
quelques mots elles ont un truc à dire
allez-y même le vois de l'état mais on a
bien compris que notre quartier c'est
pas notre mère et si un jour il doit
disparaître elle aura d'autres enfin non
vie n'ont pas de limites
le poing levé on ira partout on aimera
partout on rêvera partout et on parle
ici ici c'est le bois de l'étang
vous vouliez nous rencontrer maintenant
c'est fait et on vous fait votre
connaissance bravo c'est sur ces mots
que ça se termine d'ailleurs ce qu'on me
dit c'est ça c'est un message un message
d'ambition de ces enfants là et c'est
aussi une façon de dire que voilà dans
les quartiers dans les cités ou
n'importe où on peut aimer notre
quartier sans pour autant le défendre
bec et ongles par rapport surtout au
fait divers qu'on a vue dernièrement
entre des rixes entre quartiers etc
et c'était une façon aussi de dire que
voilà on aime notre quartier quoi qu'il
arrive mais on va pas non plus se battre
pour notre quartier quoi on part d'ici
mais on a des choses à faire aussi dans
le monde entier et ils le disent dans le
court métrage on veut laisser mieux on
va laisser mieux pour ce quartier ouais
c'est clair parce que voilà avec tout ce
qui se passe aussi au niveau de la
planète
et c'était aussi un message pour
l'environnement aussi que ces enfants là
malheureusement l'héritage qu'on leur
laisse il n'est pas il est pas top et
ces enfants là aujourd'hui
ils ont envie de laisser mieux et c'est
ce qu'ils vont faire sans nul doute j'en
suis sûr et certain
alors le 15 novembre les enfants du bois
de l'étang on va recevoir ce court
métrage barres 2d officiellement le prix
spécial des nouvelles écritures de
france télé à paris ça va être une
grande fête vous alliez vous allez
amener les enfants avec vous on va
ramener tout le monde l'a
prévu un quart avec la mairie de la
verrière donc en association avec la
mairie de la verrière donc il ya un
quart qui a été commandée donc 60 places
et tous les enfants et là bas et on va
faire la fête c'est un joueur
exceptionnel mais le lendemain il ya
école mais bon c'est un jour
exceptionnel donc on voit pas on va pas
le louper donc ça va être super
qu'est ce qu'on peut vous souhaiter pour
la suite bah pour la suite pourquoi pas
faire un long métrage avec les enfants
du bois de l'étang ce serait cool et
j'espère de très belles choses ce qu'on
peut vous dire en tout cas dès à présent
c'est bravo pour ce court métrage bravo
à vous ils vous et aux enfants salah
lydia et mohamed bravo un petit message
à légèrement de passer un message à un
coiffeur il y est ce donc qui regardent
souvent votre chaîne
d'accord il un petit cadeau pour vous
attendez je vous passe et c'est très
bien comme ça je pourrais me coiffer
avec mercy mercy moreuil à côté du conte
châtillon bah merci pour ce cadeau est
ce court métrage je rappelle qui sera
diffusé sur france 3 lors d'une grande
soirée à spécial le jeudi 6 décembre
mais vous pouvez d'ores et déjà le
retrouver sur le lien qui s'affiche en
bas de l'écran
allez c'est l'heure du dernier sujet du
journal pour le portrait de la semaine
découverte d'un artiste plaisir wa
surprenant à 29 ans en point de poussan
et passionné de cirque une discipline
qu'il découvre sur le tard lors de ses
voyages il est revenu sur les lieux de
son enfance pour pratiquer et ans et
transmettre une rencontre signée marc il
n ya qu ici l'eau c'est au cirque de
bruno est le cirque dans les étoiles à
aubergenville qu'antoine poussins vient
régulièrement s'entraîner et répété ses
numéros
je commence toujours sur son tapis de
sol en général je fais une demi heure
trois quarts d'heure des fois une heure
ça dépend et puis ensuite je commence à
dans les airs
une passion qu'il découvre tard enfant
hyperactif il a toujours été attiré par
le sport
orienté en saper plomberie il profite de
la fermeture de l'entreprise où il se
forme pour partir en quête de nouvelles
aventures
c'est en faisant de l'animation qu'ils
découvrent finalement le cirque et ses
disciplines aériennes
j'aimerais que ma fierté aujourd'hui
c'est d'être allé chercher ça de moi
même j'ai fait différents corps de
métier j'ai voyagé et ça m'a permis de
me construire et d'en être là où j'en
suis aujourd'hui
c'est ma passion tout ça c'est mes
passions réunies ce soit le cirque le
sport la scène la danse le théâtre le
c'est moi en fait donc si je peux
inspirer les enfants à l'heure de mer
peu de belles de belles images de beaux
souvenirs
un peu de créativité je le fais en
semaine en stack le meilleur de moi on
est quoi aujourd'hui on est non bien
entendu on est quoi ok très bien on va
faire les porter depuis son retour dans
les yvelines
antoin de poussan propose des stages de
cirque aux enfants pendant les vacances
scolaires
pendant une semaine les jeunes
neauphle-le-château viennent développer
leur créativité
[Musique]
après un échauffement permettant de bien
se défouler des figures les enfants
apprennent à jongler et s'essaye sur le
trapèze à force tu vas y arriver
moi c'est tombé mille fois moins que j'y
arrive
c'est l'esprit l'esprit de cirque et
puis je pense que chaque individu a sa
propre créativité et aussi sa propre
limite ce qui peut lui permettre
justement de pouvoir développer
je veux dire à sa guise de montrer des
choses qui n'ont pas encore été vu et et
ça ce que pour lui-même et pour pouvoir
inspirer les autres
1 2 3 le cirque c'est un prix des
multiples voyages et une années passées
au sein de l'association au mann heat à
marseille où il enseigne son art aux
enfants et se produit en spectacle c'est
tout naturellement à plaisir quand toi
ne poussant revient pour créer sa
micro-entreprise
j'ai eu un déclic je me suis dit j'ai
envie de te revenir
créer quelque chose fonder quelque chose
à partir d'un endroit et je pense que le
seul endroit qui m'est venu c'était
celui ci une sorte de retour aux sources
pour l'artiste qui commençait sa
formation pour devenir professeur de
cirque
il ya tout juste six ans c'est pas un
hasard pourquoi je suis arrivé dans le
cirque c'est assez drôle que ce soit
arrivé à aussi tard mon enfance
particulièrement je les ai vécus ici et
le parc du château il reflète vraiment
l'endroit où j'ai grandi
le jeune auto-entrepreneur multiplie les
activités entre l'enseignement et
l'événementiel antoine poussan a fait de
sa passion son métier c'est la fin du
journal le 7-8 loisirs à suivre dans un
instant avec marylène iapichino pour
trouver quoi faire ce week-end belle
soirée avec tv 78
[Musique]